vemos que las crisis económicas y las
violencias en esos países son los
mayores causantes de que las personas
migran hacia el norte las reuniones de
los presidentes podrían tener algún
impacto en esas causas estructurales o
para qué sirven
yo creo que son importantes para
escribir impulsando algo que el
presidente mexicano ha tomado como
prioridad desde su toma de posesión es
como comparar para temas de desarrollo
económico entre méxico y centroamérica y
cómo lograr acuerdos en comparación
incluso en temas de seguridad no
entonces yo creo que son importantes
para seguir impulsando esa sin necesidad
de tener diálogos de lograr acuerdos
para atender unas causas que fomentan la
migración centroamericana y lópez
obrador se reunirá con presidentes con
los que tiene afinidades como el cubano
miguel díaz canel o la hondureña xiomara
castró pero el líder de el salvador
nadie buque le dista mucho en las
posturas ideológicas que tanto entonces
se podría avanzar en la agenda
migratoria teniendo en cuenta esas
diferencias políticas
yo creo que depende del tema yo creo que
si aumente el tema de estrategia de
seguridad ambos se tienen muchas
diferencias lo pensador más tema de cómo
atender problemas de lo económico de
abrazos no balazos y bucle ahorita con
estado de emergencia realmente una mano
dura frente a la violencia provocada por
en particular por las pandillas pero en
temas piezas de cooperación económica si
podrían lograr afinidades y también cómo
comparar en compartir información e
inteligencia sobre este grupos
transnacionales que operan entre
centroamérica y méxico al tráfico de
drogas y de personas y como qué grupos
son estos transfronterizos de los que
usted nos habla
este grupo se creó ha organizado hay
presencia de los cárteles mexicanos en
centroamérica entonces porque mucha
necesidad de cómo fomentar más
cooperación para identificar esta
inteligencia como comparte desde la
agencia como tener investigaciones
conjuntas para atender este tema de los
grupos criminales que sí tienen sus
transnacionales también grupos de
tráfico de trato de personas señora
mayer y aunque el presidente de mexicano
andrés manuel lópez obrador no incluyó a
eeuu en su gira internacional él ya ha
viajado a este país y además es sin duda
una de las naciones más impactadas por
la migración que sale de centroamérica
en ese sentido cuáles serían los efectos
para esta nación norteamericana de las
reuniones diplomáticas del mandatario
mexicano
yo creo que méxico siempre ha sido un
socio principal de eeuu en atender la
migración regional ahorita actualmente
hay mucha cooperación entre ambos países
justamente frente a centroamérica
entiendo de asesor económico y yo creo
que busca este fomentar ese tipo de
relación y que eeuu y méxico sean
aliados con este centro américa en tema
de atender el fenómeno de la migración
regional